speaking of comics you've said that as
you became a reader in your early life
comics were a really important escape
for you from the stifling
1950s literary world of dick and jane
who are very boring people
and you've said that stan lee was one of
your greatest literary influences
as a marvel comics writer i'm
contractually obligated to ask you
about that are there lessons from comics
as a medium that you
take into your other writing
you know yes i think i'd i
you know it it would be very nice to say
that my great literary influences were
f scott fitzgerald and charles dickens
and
uh other other respected literary
figures and
tolkien of course and i admire i admire
those three writers all
enormously but stan lee was probably
more influential than any of them
the first published words of mine ever
to appear were my letter
in fantastic four number 20 which was uh
critiquing uh if you could call it a
critique
fantastic four number 17. but my
critique consisted of saying
move over shakespeare stan lee has
arrived
[Laughter]
you got to wonder why stan chose to
publish that letter
um but i'd read comic books uh
you know since i was a little kid you
know the funny animal comics
donald duck and scrooge mcduck and yeah
archie
all of that stuff um and then
superheroes especially the dc
superheroes
superman and batman and and the flash
and all that
i'd read all of those
but the minute marvel came on the scene
i think my interest in comics had
actually been waning because the dc
comics of the time were
were stifling they were perfectly
circular um you know
superman had a he was clark kent he
worked for the daily planet it was
perry white was the editor jimmy olsen
was his best friend and
uh sort of an annoying kid and uh lois
lane was his girlfriend
and something would happen aliens would
invade or there would be a villain or
something
and superman would have an adventure and
it would go circular and it would
end right where it began everything
would be back in place nothing really
ever happened
in a superman comic which i realized
after reading you know 100 or so of them
uh you could read them in any order
because uh
they had to template and nothing was
ever going to happen you know
jimmy olsen might become a giant
turtleman and during the course of the
adventure but by the end of the
adventure he would be back to being
jimmy olsen again
there was no permanent changes and then
stan lee came along with marvel
and it was the characters were fighting
in the fantastic four
the thing didn't like being the thing
and was constantly fighting with johnny
storm and they didn't have secret
identities their identities were
were out there and then spider-man came
along and
and you know spider-man he didn't have
his lowest lane he had a series of
girls he had liz allen at first who we
had the hots for
but she she preferred to bully flash
thompson and he couldn't get anywhere
with her
and then he took up with an older woman
betty brandt who was dave jonas
secretary and uh he had that
relationship for a while and he took up
with gwen stacy
that didn't work out and get it well
she died yeah that was that was
traumatic but she actually died
yeah you know i mean dc never killed
lois lane or
or even jimmy olsen although you might
have wanted to
[Laughter]
nothing ever happened in the dc's and a
lot was happening in marvel you didn't
know who was safe
and you didn't know what would what
would actually happen and time passed
i went believe it or not looking at the
old
daughter you see and have before you i
went to high school with peter parker
we were both in high school when i
started reading spider-man comics
and just about the same time we both
graduated high school and went to
college
and i went to northwestern and you know
i'm in a different city
i'm making new friends i got a roommate
that i didn't know before
i'm taking new classes it's adjusting to
a whole new war peter parker went
through the same stuff
you know he went to college and he had a
he didn't go as far away from home
he just but he did have to move out of
the house with aunt may things happened
and
and that was amazing and another one of
my comic book
letters i published a number of letters
was a letter to the avengers um
which again was published and it was
about the issue it was about avengers
number nine i think it was which is the
intro that
introduced wonder man i'm not sure any
of you remember this you're
probably all too young you probably
don't even remember wonder man but
wonder man came in and he joined the
avengers and he was a brand new hero
and he really wasn't a hero
he was a spy who set to join the
avengers to
destroy them from within so he only was
playing to be a hero but he was actually
going to destroy them from within
but then he became friendly with them
and he couldn't bring himself to destroy
them from within
so he betrayed his masters and
they killed him so he died in the same
issue that he was introduced in
and i love this of course that i wrote a
long letter
about how great this was and i look back
now and i
you know like my whole career is based
on on avengers number nine i mean
introducing these gray characters who
have divided loyalties who
are not what they seem i'm a little
traumatized
and then killing them unexpectedly yeah
yeah
now of course it was comics so they
brought wonderment back eventually but
uh
that that's the big flaw with comics and
uh i try never to bring anyone back
or if i do they're they're really
screwed up mm-hmm